même chose donc celle d'un coup de
l'entendre de la bouche de là il va y
avoir des vrais des dégâts longtemps le
le professeur en question c'est michel
desse murger et il est directeur de
recherche en neurosciences aline serbe
et sans papiers vraiment passionnant
parce que ça ça mais ne s'est presque
rassurant oui bah à tampouy ça prouve
que le truman de l'être humain
mais rien ne remplace le professeur
l'été sancya centrale selon les
observations des élèves et des étudiants
n'ont rien n'ont malheureusement rien de
surprenant plus l'effort de numérisation
augmente plus la qualité de
l'enseignement baisse plus les résultats
des élèves diminue j'ai une autre
question à vous poser
si par exemple
alors à l'heure actuelle le feu devait
le gouverneur parlement vient de donner
son feu vert à une prolongation de
l'urgent l'état d'urgence sanitaire
jusqu'au 1er juin prochain par ailleurs
si la perspective d'un confinement
finalement s'éloigner qu'on y renonce
grosso modo est ce que il faut quand
même pas je parle rapport au dossier que
le figaro publie aujourd'hui s'il faut
pas quand même réfléchir à augmenter le
nombre de places en réanimation et à
trouver quand même de sacrés quand même
des infrastructures qui permettent de
faire face à une éventuelle nouvelle van
je sais qu'on nous dit que c'est très
difficile parce qu'on crée pas des
délits dans les rayons car il faut
former informer les gens c'est le nom
que tout sa banque cherchait néo certes
certes certes mais c'est évident qu'on
voit que je sais pas ce que vous faites
rien ne nous dit on peut croiser les
doigts et espérer échapper au
confinement
d'abord on n'en sait rien mais rien ne
dit qu'on n'aura pas dans les années qui
viennent plusieurs nouveaux épisodes qui
voudraient nous obligeront à nous
confiner et plusieurs nouveaux épisodes
épidémiques aiguë on n'en sait rien de
bon qui ne seront pas forcément
respiratoires et qui bon et donc c'est
vrai que ce système où on gère tout un
pays
toute une collectivité en fonction du
nombre de lits dans des urgences à
quelque chose de l'impression qu'on
agite la queue pour bouger le chien
voyageuse qui va pas on part du résultat
pour donc on se dit que tout ce qui peut
être fait pour augmenter le nombre de
lits en réa
il ré dans le raid en virée dans le bon
sens évidemment et c'est vrai qu'on se
dit pourquoi depuis un an on n'a rien
fait rare au début on nous a dit en
trois mois on peut pas former des
infirmières hockey en six mois on peut
pas forcer à finir maintenant on en a un
on peut pas mais on envie de dire mais
est-ce qu'en deux ans pour être qu'en
trois ans pour s quand quatre emplois il
faut y mettre les moyens
oui bien sûr ça coûtera de l'argent mais
je pense que les français qu'on
fonctionne allègrement pour les impôts
etc serait tout à fait prêt à cracher au
bassinet si c'est pour des délits drea
ou pour améliorer le traitement des
personnels soignants qui est très
difficile où ils sont mal payés ou
d'ailleurs ils s'en vont parce qu'on a
un vrai sujet non seulement ne rit pas
former des infirmières mais ronald qui
s'en vont parce qu'elles sont mal payés
que la situation est trop et trop
épuisant temps dans les urgences donc
tout ce qui pourrait être fait dans ce
sens là me parler dans le bon sens quoi
qu'il arrive il est en 2d confiné nous
dit chardon bleu internautes réguliers
du figaro babineau dans les nombreux
sondages les français ne sont pas
rassurés devant la fragilité de la
situation sanitaire alors la question
qu'on posait sur twitter pensez vous
qu'il soit possible de ne plus confier
comme l'a évoqué olivier verrons ce
matin et vous répondez oui à 61 % et 7
internautes
il faudrait ouvrir des lits plutôt que
de continuer enfermé depuis un an on
pourrait vivre un peu plus n'a pas fermé
non non on n'a pas on n'a pas fermé de
la peine à augmenter mais on n'a pas
fait la même aussi quand même ouvert et
surtout mais ça heureusement par rapport
à mars avril c'est que on s'est mieux
traiter même si ces cas là de l'ortie
zones beaucoup mieux traités on a eu
aussi des morts nombreux au premier
confinement est ce que les médecins ne
savaient pas comment faire et donc quand
on arrive à l'hôpital on vous supprime
tous vos traitements
parce que on redémarre à zéro et pour un
certain nombre de malades
ça a été catastrophique voilà alors
maintenant on sait quand même mieux
faire je vous propose de passer au
deuxième thème au deuxième débat parce
que je pense que en termes de
confinement de confinement de
coronavirus on pourra y revenir la sueur
ni écharpe
franchement on pourra féliciter les
français sur leur comportement de
respect des gestes-barrières de la
conscience qu'il faut avoir
collectivement pour y est
ap parce que honnêtement quand vous
regardez l'europe c'est vraiment
exceptionnel qu'on n'y soit pas encore
franchement nos l'ensemble des français
aura compris comment il fallait se
comporter et passer quand même à
signaler
c'est notre point de vue oui moi je
trouve que les gens changent et les gens
sont l'armé au monde toujours en épingle
et royalement d'accord bon à la vérité
c'est que les gens sont extrêmement
nerveux guinée à la limite mais ils ont
compris re docilité et y compris donc
bon il faut simplement soit à trop tirer
sur la corde qui sont prêts il faut pas
les accabler de me2 mesure tatillonne
administratives manque encore de
souplesse dans les contrats qu'ils ont
compris ils ont compris
voilà et ils font aller on pose une
autre question ce soir sur twitter c'est
comment faut-il commémorer l'année
napoléon c'est le 200e anniversaire donc
de la mort de l'empereur à sainte hélène
il était raciste sexiste despotique
militariste colonialiste il ya une telle
l'install j autour de la grandeur passée
de la france qu'on lui passe tout il est
temps d'en finir avec cet aveuglement
c'est en tout cas la conviction de la
philosophe féministe et anticolonialiste
françoise vergès qui met en cause le
décret du 20 mai 1802 qui rétablit
l'esclavagé la république n'a pas à
célébrer son fossoyeur c'est en tout cas
la conviction du député insoumis et
professeur d'histoire alexis corbière
alors voici justement côté historiens ce
qu'en dit le plus grand spécialiste jean
tulard il ne faut pas effacer l'histoire
de napoléon sinon nous ne comprendrons
plus à rien au monument qui nous entoure
au nom qui nous entourent aux
institutions qui nous entourent mais
c'est encore il faut le défendre d'un
certain nombre d'accusations excessive
c'est une idée fausse que l'on se fait
que napoléon et détesté et par
conséquent je pense que monsieur macron
doit le célèbre et malgré toutes les
polémiques
malgré toutes les polémiques béatrice
même au contraire n'a pas lancé le
personnage historique préfet préféré des
français est ce que ça ne suffit pas le
faire comment même si ça pourrait
suffire à le faire quand même en ré
écouter sincèrement les déclarations
d'alexis corbières et de françoise
vergès
on connaît c'est toujours le même
discours c'est c'est absolument je
trouve stupide
voilà y'a pas d'autres termes que de la
stupidité fait rire c'est quoi cette
histoire de france alors on parlera plus
donc louis xiv on parlera publions sont
pas le plus de françois 1er on parlera
plus personne ça n'a aucun sens ce genre
de choses
bon on pourra grimper la place charles
de gaulle ce que bon me lever ou les
harkis d'apple s'est bien comportée
aguerris et françois mitterrand
l'histoire de france c'est tout voilà ce
qui ne veut pas dire qu'au moment du
bicentaire on n'évoque pas certain
nombre de choses qu'ils aient pu être
prises mais remettons les dans leur
contexte enfin quand on lit l'histoire
de d'avoir remis l'esclave agents bon
mais c'est quoi c'est dans la rivalité
avec l' empire britannique
c'est si on enlève cette rivalité france
royaume uni qui est majeur dans toute
cette fin du xviiie et tous ce début du
19ème et on comprend pas pourquoi
l'expédition d'égypte on comprend pas
rien de ce qui se passe vis-à-vis de l'
empire ottoman enfin il faut de temps en
temps un peu de prendre de distance et
regarder ce qui se passe autour de nous
que d'être dans cette attitude
nombriliste vous savez en deux en 2005
chirac n'avait pas osé c'était au
service c'est stupide mais alexis en
2005 ça suffit à faire renoncer le
jacques chirac et dominique de villepin
que le grand admirateur de napoléon nos
dirigeants soient pas courageux c'est de
la danse
et c'est vrai que villepin qui est pas
lui et voilà qui a écrit des livres des
livres tout de faire un très beau livre
sur ce qu'ils devraient geste
napoléonienne sont dégonflés parce que
déjà à l'époque mais le lob
oui c'est sûr bonne entame où l'on était
pas féministe ils n'étaient pas des
colonialistes il n'était pas
la publication d'un livre qui s'appelle
le crime de napoléon glory de claude
ribbe rue ils n'étaient pas beaucoup non
il y avait assez peu de gens rock band
est celle qui va coûter pris à la hâte
pour ce bicentenaire la russie à se
mobiliser le chili se mobilisent la
belgique se mobilisent l'italie se
mobilisent et nous on ferait rien avec
l'angleterre ça oui mais les glaciers il
est très longue durée à l'étranger
l'admiration des russes travaillent avec
les barbarians tolstoï la guerre et la
paix qu ils ont ils tant nourrit une
admiration au cas qu'il fait cela on va
y qui incroyable churchill reald blanc
qu'il avait des bus de de gaulle par
dans son bureau deux fois il faut
parfois de de gaulle n'aurait pas dû
total des revenus de ses placements donc
enfin il est d'espèces d'admiration et
nous entraîne est seul face à ce bateau
c'est démagogique est complètement
grotesque mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
nouveau il faut d'ailleurs remarquer et
c'est quelque chose donc que l'on pense
présent que dans paris y'a pas de rue
napoléon une petite rue bonaparte du
très joli mais oui mais c'est pas non
plus il n'a pas de l'avenue napoléon
rayons il ya un lycée napoléon un seul
en france à l'oncle aigles allègre
mondial alors encore non bah écoutez
j'ai vu ça tout à l'heure il ya le lycée
napoléon à l'aigle et d'ailleurs il ya
des gens de l'est qui disent que c'est
très mal il faut le débaptiser
il ya une statue de napoléon à rouen ou
le maire ya nouveau maire ps écolo on a
réparé mais donc il l'a fait enlever ont
signé les documents de consultation
citoyenne en dix ans serait peut-être
mieux d'y mettre une femme
il y des clichés gisèle halimi entre
napoléon mais j'ai pas dit non mais là
ces fonds puis alors c'est le code civil
aussi on peut peut-être dire un certain
nombre de choses sont acquises et
considérées comme sexistes à cause du
vent mais parce que c'est la femme qui
gère l'héritage
excusez moi mais partage de l'héritage
où on attend six garçons c'est quand
même napoléon bon alors il ya eu plus
sexiste que lui un manant qui se dit non
mais voilà depuis que quand acquitter d
homme à homme des grandes donc ça
n'existe il a fait fusiller le duc
d'enghien et puis il a fait tirer sur
les royalistes
et puis la vie l'europe à feu et à sang
et il a rendu la france plus petit quine
oui mais trouver les emails apporté lui
la gloire française la gloire des armes
françaises la gloire de la civilisation
de la liberté dans leur santé le chili
est ce que au moment de l'indépendance
du chili
ce sont effectivement des soldats
français qui sont allés aider à la
dépendance du chili à la demande de
bonaparte dans le tout dans l'histoire
de l'italie
le rôle de bonaparte a été aussi
important l'organisation va me dire même
d'une partie de l'administration de la
belgique est un héritage des
départements et du découpage son saut
napoléon tout le monde n'a pas tout
jeter
après la conquête de l'europe de
napoléon il a tout gagné il a tout perdu
ce qui en fait un personnage absolument
est extraordinaire mais je trouve et il
faut savoir regarder toute la complexité
des situations de merde aujourd'hui quoi
sa stupidité d'aujourd'hui passe en plus
c'est pas le enfin pire non c'est pas
bien devront donc effectivement faudrait
supprimer toutes les heures après la
notion d'ampleur que c'est quoi la
biotech françois mitterrand faudrait la
débaptiser
et puis les lycées c'est hier le jury
il ya des races supérieures et les races
supérieures ont le droit de colonne de
civiliser les races inférieures allées
jules ferry dehors et carnot à bas le
génocide vendéen vos colbert ça fait
longtemps
il va plus rester personne n'est resté
que gisèle halimi
et brice lalonde ça va être un peu court
pour faire des amis alors j'ai pas qu'au
vu de revendications bon c'est vrai
qu'il n'est rien il n'ya pas devenu
napoléon mais il ya toutes les avenues
qui sont autour de la place et les
boulevards de maria ce qui a été gagné
austerlitz comment vous expliquer par
contre que également à droite pas en
jean louis debré aujourd'hui il est
réticent font des loges je n'ai pas
d'explication simplement on a peur de
serre grande et parce que par les
féministes parler des colonialistes par
les deux armées cela on vit dans la peur
des espèces de terrorisme
heureusement qu'il ya des gens comme
tueur c'est à dire le rôle des
historiens c'est justement de remettre
en perspective les côtés sombres et les
côté lumineux
voilà et d'expliquer autrement je veux
dire on fait de l'anti histoire mais on
n'est pas les gens à penser on n'aide
pas les gens à penser la complexité on
passe dans l'offensive et remet à nantes
et c'est pas comme ça qu'on fera d'eux
des citoyens éclairés quoi donc il faut
dix on a joué un très grand grand grand
gaulliste devant l'éternel qu'il est
temps de débaptiser les amis charles de
gaulle en raison du sort réservé par
charles de gaulle aux harkis la question
de l'air il faut que la question ne
devrait pas se poser vous dit noah il
est pour moi le plus grand personnage
que l'histoire de france est connue
alors c'est un immense personnage c'est
à ccc la gloire de la france
après on peut considérer tout en disant
ça qu'il a eu à la fin un rôle
comment dire historique que la tentation
impérial n'est pas dans le génie
français et que finalement c'est une
aventure incroyable est magnifique mais
c'est une aventure qui se solde par un
échec terrible c'est vrai aussi il a
tout perdu
il ne faut pas céder aux séparatistes
aux identitaires de gauche nous dit cet
internaute napoléon fait le fait partie
de la france est comme ça nicole lycée
notre histoire quel que soit le passé
céder encore une fois des colonialistes
et antiraciste rinne
i cibles et des ados ne savent pas ce
qu'est la shoah alors napoléon il
faudrait expliquer l'histoire aux
enfants c'est primordial pour comprendre
et cet autre internaute nous dit quoi
qu'il ait fait il faut l'enseigner aux
élèves
l'histoire s'est instruit évite bien des
réactions infantile c'est pas
l'historienne de formation qui est
béatrice giblin qui je pense vous
contredira chers internautes
je vous appelle chat internet parce que
vous appelez une autre dent comme ceux
donnés c'est un peu compliqué mais merci
en tout cas de votre commentaire alors
est ce que vous savez ce qui est d'un
pôle et on a dit on aurait dit en tous
les cas sur la tombe de rousseau alors
eh bien il aurait mieux valu que lui
comme moi n'existions pas nous n'ayons
pas exister une soirée et alors c'est
appris samedi auprès d'apple
ça lui a lancé qu'il ne lui devait oui
justement ça va toujours frapper mais
j'ai toujours je trouve la nuit pour
champ souvenir alors je ne sais pas si
c'était las cases quelqu'un mais le
déprime un peu sur la tombe donc de
rousseau il l'a dit ça ça m'a toujours
frappé donc comme la partager et la
vérifier avec vous jamais de vote doute
donc mais dont on regrettera alexis de
faire chaque de faire une vérif trouvé
sur le sur le site du figaro on vous
pose la question tous les cas sur le
site du figaro sur si la république doit
rendre un hommage officiel à napoléon et
tout à l'heure au début de cette
émission il y avait 73 % de oui et c'est
toujours le cas actuellement vous pouvez
continuer à voter et on vous pose
également la question sur twitter où il
y avait également 70 % de oui merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis est ce
qu'on fera des aveugles
on se retrouve
demain alors effectivement les invalides
ont existé quand même oui j'adore
permanemment napoléon par leur sortie et
vous voyez c'est choquant 1 avec tous
ces drapeaux et trouve peut-être qu'il y
aura une cérémonie gratuit c'est la
libye cela nous et on retient donc les
suggestions et peut-être qu'on mettra
vos votes justement les suggestions et
d'alexis dans un prochain décret merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis à très
vite sur le site du figaro et si on sort
justement les cendres de napoléon on
espère que la cérémonie sera grandiose
et qu'on pourra leur transmettre sans
fil à très vite
[Musique]